here are some celebrities who used to be
famous but ended up living very normal
non-f famous lives the kid who played
Charlie in the original Willy Wonka he
went on to become a Vetinarian and
remember Chunk from The Goonies he went
on to become a lawyer this one honestly
surprised me I used to love this show
but I never really thought about this
actress until now so the girl who played
Harper on Wizards of Waverly Place is an
RN now hm and last but not least Hayden
Christensen who did all the Star Wars
movies bought a f Farm outside of
Toronto and he's now all about farming
and is so far removed from Hollywood and
any of the acting share with me all your
thoughts on this in the comments below